pretty terrifying sounding numbers there
but how significant is this
thanks for having me on rich so listen i
think it's really important to zoom out
and always look at the bigger picture
how significant is it well we have just
had a two-year bull market so it's very
normal and very natural to start to see
things to start and cool off during that
bull market we saw central banks print
unprecedented amounts of money people
were putting that money putting their
stimulus checks in the us and the
equivalent in the uk into bitcoin
helping prop up the market we're now
seeing um unprecedented levels of
inflation 40 year high so people simply
don't have that surplus cash to put into
bitcoin and all these other alternative
asset classes central banks are starting
to take um inflation seriously and as a
result their goal is seeing quantitative
tightening so interest rates are going
up um and so people again don't have
that surplus cash unfortunately anymore
they don't want to be defaulting on
their mortgages they need that liquid
cash so in terms of how significant is
it it's not that significant for me in
my opinion this is very normal bitcoin
is still um a very immature asset this
is still a very new market we also have
to consider the geopolitical situation
you know we just had two year lock downs
we're seeing um supply chain issues a
war going on between russia and ukraine
you mentioned that earlier on on your um
on your news program and so markets
don't like wars bitcoin is still
supposed to be considered that risk on
asset so naturally people will start to
sell their riskiest assets during these
times
you mentioned central banks investments
inflation one of the selling points of
cryptocurrencies is that it's
decentralized it's kind of insulated
somewhat
from the decisions that these
organizations and individual countries
make talk us through some of the other
factors that have had an impact
in the cryptocurrency price drop
well everything that i've just mentioned
is clearly going to instill a lot of
fear uncertainty and doubt so naturally
the price is going to fall more however
we are starting to see some interesting
black swan events so we're seeing major
liquidations three arrows um capital for
example they are a crypto hedge fund so
they had 200 um million dollars worth of
ether coins which is the second biggest
crypto by market cap and totally
liquidated wipes off the market we're
seeing um other major reputable
cryptocustodians that people really
trust and have their life savings on
these exchanges on these custodians like
celsius networks start to approach their
liquidation price and so if they are
liquidated and we do see this happen
people's life savings are going to be
wiped off the market there was also a
major event that happened um which
totally destabilized the market um a
couple of weeks ago this was with tara
luna so without getting too complicated
this was a
supposed stable coin pegged one-to-one
with the us dollar it lost its peg
people were getting 20
interest which was supposed to be
risk-free supposedly a lot of major
reputable people were promoting this as
risk-free people had their life savings
earning 20 interest and this depends um
and people lost millions and millions of
dollars hence the reason why the market
is getting lower and lower